what's up reject nation we are going to
start today
gravity falls uh i know nothing about
this show no nothing i know i'm not this
is uh highly recommended via comments
and i know why so this blind wave
started up a few weeks ago i
see the pattern that happened gotta
follow in the footsteps of greatness
so
thanks guys for recommending it and uh
since we wrapped up arcane and then
chucky's ending for us too we're like oh
yeah let's we should throw another show
onto the docket here
why it might as well and gravity falls
uh here's a short one and sounds like a
lot of fun even though i i don't know
why it would sound like a lot of fun
since i
i don't know anything about it
i don't know what it sounds like you
guys keep saying it it's so sure it'd be
nice to watch something it's like a
little bit lighter hopefully we'll see
guys if you hit that like button that'd
be great subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next episode is up
as always full length watch along as we
sing it with the time code for gravity
falls we'll be at our patreon page over
there we cover a bunch of shows with the
same tier you get the option for both
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included lastly thank you to the boys at
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights
let's see what the show's about
[Music]
ah summer break so do you want cheese on
that hun
a time for leisure
recreation and take it are easy
unless you're me
my name is dipper the girl about to puke
is my sister mabel you may be wondering
what we're doing in a golf cart fleeing
from a creature of unimaginable horror
rest assured there's a perfectly logical
explanation okay
the show begins it all began when our
parents decided we could use some fresh
air they shipped us up north to a sleepy
town called gravity falls oregon to stay
at our great uncle's place in the woods
mystery shack attic is amazing check out
all my splinters
the kristen shaw
hey friend
oh
yes you can keep chewing on my sweater
my sister tended to look on the bright
side of things
[Music]
and then there was our great uncle stan
that guy
[Laughter]
was worth it
it was worth it
ladies and gentlemen behold the sass
crotch
i want to go there it looked like it was
going to be the same boring routine all
summer
until one fateful day
[Music]
he's looking at it he's looking at it uh
do you like me
yes definitely absolutely
[Laughter]
i rigged it
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's my big chance to have an epic
summer romance yeah but do you need to
flirt with every guy you meet
my name is mabel but you can call me the
girl of your dreams
i'm just oh yeah
i wouldn't be surprised if the man of my
dreams walk through that door right now
[Music]
oh oh not good ow that's illegal grunkle
stan whenever i'm in those woods i feel
like i'm being watched ah this again i'm
telling you something weird is going on
in this town just today my mosquito
bites spelled out beware
that says be warb
grunkle stan nobody ever believes
anything i say
huh
what
oh christmas town oh
what the
the necronomicon
[Music]
it's hard to believe it's been six years
since i began studying the strange and
wondrous secrets of gravity falls oregon
[Music]
what is all this your season adventures
i'm being watched i must hide this book
before he finds it remember in gravity
falls there is no one you can trust
no one you can trust it's nothing
[Music]
are you actually not gonna show me
uh
who's that well time to spill the beans
rope
beans stupid
let me get this straight in the half
hour i was gone you already found a
boyfriend what can i say i mean this is
the first day come on oh
oh coming
what you reading there slick oh i was
just catching up on uh
gold chains for old men
[Laughter]
stupid
oh god
hey how's it hanging we met at the
cemetery he's really deep oh little
muscle there that's
what a surprise
what's your name
normal
normal man
so you want to go gold hands or whatever
oh
oh my goodness
don't wait up
there was something about norman that
wasn't uh
pale skin and bad attitudes these
creatures are often mistaken for
teenagers beware gravity falls is
nefarious
[Music]
somebody say
crumby what is that crumby it's not even
a word you're losing your mind
rob crumby
seuss you've seen mabel's boyfriend he's
got to be a zombie right look dude i
believe you i'm always noticing weird
stuff in this town like the mailman
pretty sure that dude's a werewolf
[Music]
[Laughter]
my sister could be in trouble it was
time to get some evidence
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we've got to talk about norman isn't he
the best check out this giant smooch
mark he gave me
[Music]
gullible it was just an accident with
the leaf blower
[Music]
kissing practice oh
no
oh golly oh girly
[Music]
it's not what he seems
you think he might be a vampire that
would be so awesome guess again sister
shaban
gnomes
ma'am a zombie that is not funny dipper
i'm not joking it all adds up the
bleeding the limp he never blinks have
you noticed that maybe he's blinking
when you're blinking
i don't have any real evidence
i guess i can be kind of paranoid
sometimes wait what
yes
maybe it's a prosthetic you can tell me
anything please be a vampire please be a
vampire just keep an open mind be cool
yeah way to go show
long story short us gnomes have been
looking for a new queen right guys
oh my
i'm sorry guys you're really sweet but
i'm a girl and you're gnomes and it's
like what
yikes but gnomes are real that's right
and they're just living
more you struggle the more awkward this
is gonna be for everybody just okay
let's get her arm there steve gross
the frame that launched a thousand memes
gnomes little men of the gravity falls
forest weaknesses unknown oh come on
you think you can stop us boy you have
no idea what we're capable of the gnomes
are a powerful race do not trifle with
them
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you've messed with the wrong creatures
boy gnomes of the forest assemble
oh gnome
hell gnome
hurry before they come after us i
wouldn't worry about it see their little
legs the suckers are tiny
oh no
[Music]
ah
gnome zord
[Music]
come back with our queen it's getting
closer
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
[Music]
thanks mabel don't mention it
oh
buddy
where's grunkle stan
behold the world's most distracting
object
just this once trust me
huh
[Music]
hey wait a
thanks for minute to me
thanks for breaking my heart oh my faith
this is for messing with my brother
wanna do the otters on three one two
three
[Laughter]
no pollution no
i accidentally overstocked some
inventory so uh how's about each of you
take one item from the gift shop on the
house you know really what's the catch
the catches do it before i change my
mind
replacement hat and i will have a
grappling hook
would you rather have like a doll or
something
grappling hook fair enough
this journal told me there was no one in
gravity falls i could trust but when you
battle a hundred gnomes side by side
with someone you realize that they've
probably always got your back
hey mabel could you get the light
i'm on it oh god
our uncle told us there was nothing
strange about this town but who knows
what other secrets are waiting to be
unlocked like what does the uncle know
yeah what are you hiding grunkle stan
[Music]
it's got the cola chad
oh no
trap back there
get that meme
t-shirts who watch the whole filters
oh boy what a pilot oh my god it was an
adventure and a half
well that was uh exactly what i expected
going into this blind not knowing a
thing about gravity falls
i was like i feel like
i have an idea what this show is going
to be like and then sure enough
nailed it this was like
i i must have had like a premonition or
something
because this was exactly what i thought
it would be called there it was called
there for sure has it been a dream no i
was not expecting something as
hyper kinetic as it was but the kind of
physical comedy and
the
banter that occurs of this like the
self-aware
jokes
that's my jam right there yeah that's
totally my jam
and it's a really good pilot to set up
like you have the what's the guy's name
dipper dipper and dipper yeah like a big
dipper yeah and then you got mabel yeah
this there
maple's the kind of character that
normally would annoy the [ __ ] out of me
but for some reason i thought she was
freaking hilarious here she's my
favorite part of the whole episode
forget it she just cracked me up for
some reason yeah she's the right pitch
of that like yeah i could easily become
obnoxious but it's the right pitch of
quirk
yeah it's like silly but not too much
yeah it was perfect in my opinion yeah
and uh then our main guy i like this
like the setup it lends itself to
something more
uh adventurous to come because the fact
that they have you going that it's
probably gonna be a zombie
i didn't actually see a mislead i
thought i was like is that a human or a
zombie that's all i thought it was gonna
be but then to have the gnome thing come
around was actually pretty clever
because first thing you see is the gnome
in the book and then they they open up
they like they're telling you gnome yeah
yeah the mistaken pull of no wait no no
no no zombies yeah yeah yeah they're
looting that it's probably going to be
gnome and then the way they flesh it out
meaning that this world if it has the
gnomes it should at least still have the
zombies it's just to have the wearable
just a lot of all the cool ghouls and
creatures that are to await us and of
course like the setup with the uncle who
has a bit of that rick vibe to him but
not fully you know like yes he's got
kind of that that cadence of delivery
the raspy scratchy voice the uh the
guardian who doesn't seem that
responsible for the youth characters
yeah who's always got a scheme yeah yeah
yeah a little skeezy and whatnot but um
i like that they let us in that he does
know more than what's actually going on
a lot of his jokes are really funny too
yeah and the and the animation and the
whimsy i thought was just it's like this
is is it's a disney at the top it's a
disney show i thought it was on like
cartoon network at the time i don't know
anything about it but maybe they
acquired it or maybe yeah i don't really
know much on that side but i'm surprised
maybe to see their name on it just
because this you know feels very kid
accessible but not necessarily aimed at
kids like feels disney xd to me yeah it
feels more like young teenager and
at all but sort of aimed most directly
towards yeah that age bracket where it's
a little bit more mature and there's a
little bit more of that sort of lexicon
like yeah like there's lots of fanciful
creatures and stuff that i think we can
expect that are just at home in a kid's
fantasy world but i feel like they're
probably going to do a lot of
fun pulls for movies and shows and play
on your you know expectations based on
certain creatures even you know like
like i wouldn't have seen the gnomes
thing coming around but they they do a
nice job of of
you know like playing with what you know
about zombies like i love that whole
montage of them like out on their date
and everything that happens to norman is
like another zombie image that's classic
yeah just know instinctually
um so yeah it's like i can i can easily
see how this is sort of like one of
those crossover hits that like adults
really like but also kids can easily
access yeah it's fun for all ages yeah
it's got great physical gags throughout
ah dude the freaking uh six-pack
as much as in the in the past years of
visiting small towns and getting more
acquainted with what small town
personalities are like i really feel
like they brought that to life here yeah
yeah in a lot of ways like the small
town vibe yeah the like like woodsy
mountainy sort of isolated board
yeah yeah yeah it's like everything is
way more spread out much more analog and
there's not very like there's not
service up here like a great place if
you're from the city to go visit because
it's quaint it's peaceful it's quiet but
then if you live there you're
you're kind of just bored
like i like it almost reminds me of like
a fun madcap family accessible like twin
peaks in that way you have this
well and i wonder you know if that's in
the sauce because yeah like there is a
sort of like small town like some
strange here but also everyone just kind
of knows each other and yeah it is kind
of like slow and sleepy you know but
there's also
like there's lots bubbling beneath the
surface
and i can see this this show kind of
pulling from there
you know at least potentially speaking
it's a great title
yeah it is it really is i can actually
think about that
gravity falls
wow yeah it's like a perfect metaphor
and it sounds like a town
yeah yeah it sounds like things are
gonna go turn upside down absolutely i
love it love this love the sound of it
yeah no it's a really good pilot i liked
it a lot liked it a lot um so i don't
know i would imagine that as it
progresses it probably just gets even
better from here yeah yeah and i'll
probably i imagine the pace in the
rhythm will will you know
sort of find its quintessential whip
crack level you know yeah because at
first it's a bit of sensory overload if
you're going in blind yeah absolutely
yeah so yeah it's like i fully expect
over the next like over at least the
first season to see kind of them hone
and tweak the energy and the pace and
the humor voice but this is a as far as
like all pilots go like this feels well
full yeah i mean i remember like
rick and morty is not um a much more
adult show than this
and
much more sci-fi
uh they're very different in a lot of
ways i could see
a version where people might compare it
but i remember like even rick and morty
a show that i i fell absolutely in love
with uh the pilot did not really hook me
and
so but this to me
i was more gravity comparatively
speaking i was more gravitated towards
this pilot that i was like rick and
morty so on that note i'd imagine that
as the show progresses it'd probably
just get better yeah
one watching other shows like a
supernatural like it gets you and being
that you know like this is in you know a
tighter package it's 20 minutes like it
gets you excited for just the promise of
like oh man we're going to see so many
creatures and things and and like yeah
everybody do vibe to it yeah yeah
absolutely and it feels like you won't
necessarily even be confined like i'm
sure each episode will have one major
thing at the center of it but you won't
be confined to just one mysterious
happening or whatever throughout the
show and i think that's another fun
portent is the you know the the breadth
of absurdity you can access in this
medium yeah yeah
all right guys well gravity follows
thanks so much for recommending this our
way this is quite enjoyable make sure to
subscribe click that like button and hey
we'll catch you guys soon
you